[Musique]
merci Matthieu Darnaud de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure élu de l'Ardèche m du groupe
les républicains nouveau premier
vice-président du Sénat on va en parler
on va évidemment parler dans quelques
instants de votre texte adopté cette
nuit sur la protection des élus mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est Israël le
sujet à occuper vous l'avez vu une
grande partie des questions d'actualité
à l'Assemblée nationale il en sera de
même cet après-midi ici au Sénat oui
tout à fait qu'est-ce que vous attendez
encore du gouvernement je crois un
discours de de clarté quand je regarde
les propos tenus par la France insoumise
par Madame Panau je pense qu'il est des
sujets sur lequels on ne peut pas
cultiver l'ambiguïé il faut être clair
ce sont des actes atroces qui ont été
commis qui qui nous interpellent qui qui
nous touche au au plus profond quand on
est un être humain quand on voit les
massacres qui ont eu lieu des enfants
qui ont eu la tête décapité pardon mais
comment tout ceci ne peut pas nous
interpeller quand bien même on considère
que et c'est une évidence tout doit être
fait pour retrouver le le le chemin de
la paix mais rappelons quand même qu'on
a une organisation le Hamas qui appelle
à la destruction
d'Israël il y a quand même une forme
d'ambivalence pardon à à ce dire on veut
tendre vers la paix avec une
organisation qui a dans sa charte et
comme objectif la destruction d'une
démocratie qui est Israël vous voyez il
y a une ambigué qui est assez
insupportable et pardon de dire mais je
pense que la classe politique doit être
très clair dans ses propos condamné et
je le dis sans ambiguïé soutenir
aujourd'hui un peuple qui vient de de
vivre de telleles mais qui n'est pas
assez clair à part la France insoumise
ah ben ça ça suffit déjà c'est un
certain nombre de de députés je pense
qu'à un moment donné est-ce que le Parti
socialiste doit défaire l'alliance avec
l'ANU doit se séparer de la France je
suis pas là pour parler à la place du du
Parti socialiste certains ont déjà fait
montre des plus grandes réserves va
continuer à travailler avec la la France
insoumise euh je pense qu'il faut une
clarté une clarté parce que c'est c'est
des sujets qui sont trop importants pour
qu'on puisse se permettre quelque
ambigué que ce soit votre collègue
sénateur Stéphane lerulier il appelle à
dissoudre la France insoumise faut aller
jusque là non mais ça jeallais dire il
appartient au ministre de l'Intérieur il
l'a fait d'ailleurs je crois s'agissant
du du
NPA avec l'ouverture de d'une enquête
pour apologie du du du terrorisme euh je
pense parce qu'il faut effectivement de
rien laisser passer après il faut voir
les les faits dans le dans dans le
détail pour aller pour aller plus loin
mais estce qu'il y a une forme
d'antisémitisme de la part de LFI selon
vous si on je veux dire je peux pas
parler ainsi en tout cas tout ce qui
encore une fois procède de de l'ambiguïé
fait le terreot de l'antisémitisme
Stéphane lul encore lui il appelle aussi
à pénaliser l'antisionisme c'est une
proposition de loi que vous soutiendrez
je prendrai connaissance de de cette
proposition de loi je pense que
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on on ne cesse
d'éveiller de réveiller les consciences
dans notre pays face à ce qu'il se passe
vous l'avez rappelé un nombre d'actions
antisémites ont eu lieu sur notre
territoire on ne peut pas accepter ça je
le dis on ne peut pas en 2023 accepter
de telles choses donc tout ce qui
permettra de renforcer par la loi mais
aussi par les moyens par l'éducation et
j'y reviens mais par j'allais dire un
disc cours clair de la classe politique
va dans le bon sens sur l'Union
européenne l'Union européenne s'est
prononcé hier contre une suspension de
l'aide aux Palestiniens est-ce que vous
vous la demandez je pense qu'il faut là
aussi avoir une lecture très très fine
du du sujet ne pas confondre Palestine
le Hamas je pense qu'il faut faire œuvre
de pédagogie dans la période faut pas
couper tout d'aide au développement
parce que certains républain les demand
ne pas confondre l'aide au développement
par contre veillez à ce que l'aide soit
bien identifie bien fléché parce que
effectivement il peut y avoir un lien
ténu et ça peut concourir
malheureusement à soutenir certaines
organisations donc être très vigilant VO
est-ce qu'il faut aussi revoir nos
relations avec certains pays notamment
le Qatar là aussi je pense qu'il faut
être faut être exigeant je pense qu'on
ne peut pas fermer les yeux sur
certaines réalités et il faudra le faire
à l'onne de ce qui vient de se se passer
moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui se
contente d'fement ou ou d'annonce pour
faire pour faire un buzz médiatique je
crois que ce sont des sujets trop graves
pour que l'on n'it pas une lecture très
fine mais à l'évidence si certains faits
sont sont sont confirmés il faudra
prendre le temps d'avoir cette lecture
fine comme je le disais et effectivement
peut-être s'interroger sur certaines
certaines relations que l'on peut avoir
avec d'autres avec d'autres pays on va
parler de l'actualité du Sénat le Sénat
qui cette nuit a adopté à l'unanimité
votre texte pour renforcer c'est la
sécurité des élus on va voir les temps
forts de cette séance avec Steve
[Musique]
Jourdan bonjour Steve bonjour bonjour
monsieur le sénateur bonjour et Steve le
Sénat donc adopté cette proposition de
loi pour mieux protéger les élus
notamment les maires oui 14 mesures
concrètes pour renforcer cette
protection des mesures qui s'inscrivent
dans un contexte d'aggravation des
violence un nouveau KPM en train d'être
franchi selon vous selon les sénateurs
les atteintes à l'encontre des élus
locaux sont en constante augmentation on
se rappelle évidemment de l'affaire de
Saint-Brévin où le maire Yanni crodz
avait été contraint de démissionner
suite à des menaces suite à des
intimidation en 2022
1387 faits ont été recensés contre les
élus locaux dans 3/4s des cas ce sont
les merses qui sont visées quelques
éléments rienent sur et bien la nature
de ces violences plus plus de 12 % de
ces faits sont des violences physiques
les violences verbales comme les menaces
de mort par exemple constituent quant à
elle 76 % de l'ensemble des violences
une situation qui n'est plus tenable oui
le gouvernement tarde à prendre le
phénomène à bras le corp du coup le
Sénat vient à la rescousse parmi les
mesures adoptées hier on retrouve
notamment le renforcement des sanctions
pénales le texte prévoit de porter les
sanctions maximales de 5 à 7 ans de
prison en cas en cas d'agression contre
un élu c'est un alignement des peines et
bien sûr celle prévue en cas de violence
commise contre les forces de l'or le
texte prévoit également l'amélioration
de la prise en charge des victimes de
violence ou encore le renforcement de
l'information des maires sur la
possibilité sur même et bien la
nécessité de déposer plainte il faut
savoir que seulement 37 % des élus
saisissent la justice suite à la suite
d'une agression c'est les chiffres de la
commission des Lois du Sénat large
consensus sur ce dossier St oui avant le
vote le texte AAC recueilli la signature
de 200 sénateurs de la droite et du
centre il reçoit aussi l'appui déterminé
du gouvernement écoutez votre travail a
été absolument décisif le le
gouvernement est donc favorable dans
leur principe à l'ensemble des mesures
portées par cette proposition de loi en
matière pénale y compris celle que vous
avez adopté en
commission le Gouvernement est également
favorable à la très grande majorité des
mesures visant à accompagner les élus
victimes ou à renforcer la prise en
compte des réalités des mandats électifs
locaux par les acteurs judiciaires et
étatiques Tex adopté à la majorité à une
large majorité hier par le Sénat
monsieur le sénateur après la démission
du maire de sa 20 le gouvernement avait
promis des initiatives avait fait des
promesses il fallait aller plus loin oui
c'est alors c'est c'est pas nouveau hein
le Sénat depuis 2019 avec Philippe Bas
alors président de la commission des
lois nous avions entamé une large
concertation auprès de tout les maires
et les élus de France à la suite du
décès du du maire de de signe
jean-mthieu Michel considérant qu'on ne
pouvait plus continuer comme ça que
quand on est dépositaire de l'autorité
publique on ne peut pas faire l'objet de
menac de violence quotidienne et je
pense qu'il fallait aller plus loin le
Sénat est à l'œuvre depuis maintenant 4
ans sur ce sujet que ce soit au travers
des des travaux de la commission des
lois de la délégation aux collectivités
territoriales avec la présidente
Françoise Gattel nous avions à l'époque
avec Jean-Marie Boquel fait des
propositions sur le statut de l'élu qui
prenaient en compte cette question des
des violences faites aux élus et qui
déjà anticipai les propositions qui
aujourd'hui ont trouvé une
concrétisation dans dans ce cette
proposition de de de loi notamment par
rapport à à la prise en compte des
victimes à l' à l'automatisation pardon
de la la
protection fonctionnelle
juridictionnelle c'était quelque chose
d'important au fait de l'élargir aux
élus départementaux régionaux et puis si
josis je dirais qu'il faut aller
maintenant au-delà du texte de loi j'ai
rendu un un rapport sur l'avenir de de
de la commune pour essayer aussi de voir
quelles étaient sur les territoires les
bonnes pratiques j'ai vu notamment dans
la Somme mamien que le procureur de la
République avait dédié un personnel à
ses relations avec les élus pour que
ceux-ci qui sont souvent très isolés
face à ces phénomènes de violence à une
brutalité auquel on n' pas l'habitude
d'être confronté ils ont besoin d'être
entendus qu'on renforce ce lien entre la
justice le parquet les élus et je pense
qu'il faut s'inspirer de ce qui
fonctionne bien qu'il faut des moyens à
l'évidence pour compléter l'arsenal
législatif moyen financier financier
humain pour donner sentiment aux élus
qu'ils ne sont pas seuls les maires ils
nous disent aussi il y a un problème
avec la réponse pénale elle est
insuffisante aujourd'hui bah elle est en
tout cas trop lente selon selon leur
dire et c'est pour ça que nous avons
souhaité qu'il puisse avoir une réponse
plus rapide pour que ces mêmes élus
aient la capacité de de savoir très
rapidement si leur plainte fait l'objet
d' d'une suite ou si elle estquement une
question de lenteur c'est une question
aussi de moyen vous savez dans dans les
diff question de l' pour pour en avoir
discuté avec plusieurs procureurs de la
la République il manque de moyens ils
ont un nombre de plaintes hors les
plaintes des élus et je pense
qu'effectivement dans un temps et ça
nous ramène au sujet que nous ébordions
tout à l'heure où la violence euh ne
fait que croître dans notre pays les
élus ne sont pas épargnés ils sont ce ce
cœur battant de de notre démocratie et
il faut effectivement que leur
protection soit une priorité absolue et
peut-être créer un statut particulier
pour les élus bien sûr j'allais dire
cette cette PPL elle fait suite et vous
l'avez rappelé euh aux travaux que nous
avons menés à l'occasion notamment de
l'agression du maire de de de de
Saint-Brévin euh d'une rare brutalité
d'une rare violence où on a constaté
qu'il fallait tous euh être acteur de la
protection des élus que ce soit la
justice que ce soit le Parlement mais
que ce soit aussi l'état préfait
sous-préfet les forces de police et de
gendarmerie c'est un ensemble euh
d'acteurs qu'il faut mettre
autour de la table et qui agissent en
cohérence parce que là encore une fois
je pense que le sentiment d'abandon des
Maes n'a jamais été aussi fort et il n'y
a qu'une réponse collective qui
permettra de de sortir par le haut de
donner le sentiment aux élus qu'ils ne
sont encore une fois mais qu'est-ce que
vous attendez cation de de de ce statut
de l'élu David Lisnard il dit il faut
reposer la question des indemnités
est-ce que vous attendez ça aussi la
question du cumul entre le métier et la
fonction de Mare bien sûr
aujourd'hui on a travaillé vous le savez
sur la question des secrétaires de
mairie considérant qu'il fallait
revaloriser je vais dire cette fonction
qui est essentielle pour travailler au
côté des mairres singulièrement des
mairres dans les dans les plus petites
communes parce que c'est finalement ce
ce ce tandem utile au fonctionnement
de de nos communes on est soutenu par
par le par le gouvernement mais le
statut de l'élu moi je préfère qu'on
dise les conditions d'exercice du du
mandat local c'est un ensemble de choses
qui va bien sûr de la question des
indemnités parce qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart et notamment chez les les jeunes
élus qui rentrent dans dans dans le
mandat il faut cumuler parfois prendre
un temps partiel quand on quand on
travaille donc perdre une part de son
revenu c'est aussi le cumul des heures
quand on quand on a une une fonction et
une profession pardon c'est encore la
prise en compte comme on l'a fait à
l'époque pour les les sapeurs pompiers
de de cette expérience d'élus dans le
calcul euh de sa de de sa retraite c'est
aussi la capacité d'aborder tous les
sujets qui font le quotidien et
d'ailleurs il figure dans dans le
rapport que j'ai eu l'occasion de rendre
au mois de juillet avec maris carer euh
pour l'avenir de l'élu parce que ce qui
est en cause disons les choses très
clairement c'est l'avenir de notre
démocratie locale jamais autant d'élus
locaux plus de 30000 euh ont démissionné
depuis qu'ils sont entrés en fonction en
2020 un nombre de démissions de maire
qui n'a jamais été aussi important et
surtout des nuages qui ne cessent de
s'amonceler au-dessus de nos têtes avec
de plus en plus de maires y compris de
nouveaux maires qui affirme avec
certitude ne plus vouloir se représenter
en 2026 et derrière des gens qui ne
veulent pas prendre la succession est-ce
que vous redoutez une crise des
voocation en 2026 est-ce que vous
redoutez qu'un grand nombre de communes
se retrouve sans candidat très
clairement on avait 110 communes en 2020
je pense qu'on sera bien au-delà en 2026
je crois qu'il vaut faire de de la la
vitalité de notre démocratie locale une
priorité absolue parce que en réalité si
vous faites si vous jetez un regard sur
ce qui vient de se passer la crise
sanitaire qui a été en première ligne
les élus locaux quand quand il s'est
agit pardon de mettre en place les
protocoles scolaires l'acheminement des
masques les centres de vaccination le
contact direct avec la population la
crise énergétique un peu plus proche de
nous c'est encore les élus qui ont été
en première ligne le quotidien tout ce
qui fait finalement que nos concitoyens
ont besoin d'avoir un lien très direct
de voir la proximité être renforcé tout
ça passe par les élus locaux nous nous
croyons à cette France communale qui est
peut-être une singularité en Europe avec
un nombre de communes plus important
mais qui permet d'être le meilleur des
amortisseurs dans toutes les crises et
de renforcer le lien social et ça passe
aussi peut-être par une nouvelle étape
de la décentralisation que vous appelez
vœux vous pensez qu'Emmanuel Macron va
enclencher cette réforme vous l'espérez
vous avez des retours làdus ah je pense
que c'est une absolue nécessité en
réalité souvent quand j'écoute euh les
informations quand je me rends compte
qu'on parle de quasiment tous les sujets
sauf de celui qui me paraît peut-être un
des plus importants c'est-à-dire la
décentralisation al c'est souvent un
barbarisme parce que nos concitoyens ne
voient pas ce qu'il y a derrière ce
terme moi je dis que dans mon
département les décisions qui concernent
le quotidien de nos concitoyens elles
doivent être prises ces décisions à
Privat dans la préfecture plutôt qu'à
Paris et ça doit être vrai pour tous les
départements parce que pardon de le dire
il est des vérités territoriales qui ne
peuvent être prises en en compte qu'en
permettant de rapprocher la prise de
décision du citoyen et la
décentralisation au fond c'est ça c'est
faire en sorte manuel Macron il en a
parlé devant le Conseil constitutionnel
il a parlé de décentralisation inachevée
ça a raisonné à vos oreilles oui si José
je dirais qu'en 2017 nous étions ici au
Sénat pour écouter le chef de l'État
nouvellement élu nous parler de la
décentralisation et qu' a quelques
exceptions prêtes on entendait à peu
près ce genre de de discours je crois la
fameuse conférence des territoires moi
je suis pragmatique et sincèrement je je
l'espère et je ne fais pas d'ironie sur
ce sujet-là parce que je pense que c'est
un sujet trop important pour que
aujourd'hui nous ne mettions pas je vais
dire tous les moyens pour pour y arriver
et si c'est l'ambition du chef de l'État
du gouvernement de nos collègues députés
je pense que toute initiative sera
bienvenue et je puis vous assurer comme
l'a dit le président Larcher puisque il
a conduit et présidé le groupe de
travail sur la décentralisation qui lui
aussi a rendu ses travaux au mois de
juillet nous sommes prêts au Sénat à
faire œuvre utile et aller loin dans
cette décentralisation mais vous pensez
qu'Emmanuel Macron il est prêt à aller
jusqu'où lui c'est à lui de nous le dire
il a fait montre d'intention je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous attendons des actes
nous attendons un grand texte comme il
l'avait lui-même appelé de ses vœux puis
c'est un nouvel acte de décentralisation
et de déconcentration parce qu' aussi je
crois que l'État territorial
enquel je crois profondément doit
pouvoir être cet équilibre au côté des
collectivités qui permet justement de
rapprocher la prise de décision du
citoyen mais est-ce qu'il faut aller
jusqu'à remettre à plat le millefeuille
territoriale est-ce qu'il faut supprimer
des échelons je pense qu'il faut déjà
commencer par la par la décentralisation
euh c'est je trouve que pardon de le
dire mais le débat sur le sur le
millefeuille c'est souvent une façon
d'éviter le sujet de la décentralisation
et de la déconcentration commençons par
dire concrètement ce que l'on veut y
compris sur le champ constitutionnel moi
je pense je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut revisiter l'article
72 pour donner notamment au préfets des
départements un pouvoir dérogatoire
parce que sinon on le constate à chaque
fois à chaque fois qu'il y a un sujet
dans un territoire euh on invite le
législateur à à revisiter euh les textes
en vigueur je pense qu'il serait
beaucoup plus simple qu'on puisse
adapter assouplir dans le cadre euh de
de la loi euh certaines problématiques
certains sujets à l'on de la vérité de
chacun de nos nos territoires on a des
sujets moi je vi un territoire très
rural un territoire de de montagne a des
sujets qui ne se posent pas de la même
manière que sur le territoire du du
littoral et je pense qu'un préfet peut
tout à fait en concertation avec les
collectivités agir pour assouplir ou
pour prendre en compte ces spécificités
il y a une question qui va se poser à
vous dans les 6 mois à venir en matière
de décentralisation c'est la question de
l'autonomie de la Corse puisqueemmanuel
Macron ouvert la voie il a donné 6 mois
au parlementaires pour trouver un texte
constitutionnel est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à la v mais encore une fois je je
pense qu'il faut voir ce qu'il y a
dedans ça fait combien de temps depuis
combien de temps qu'on parle de de la
Corse ça fait un an et demi qu'il y a eu
cette promesse vers leutom oui mais mais
pareil pour la la question de la
différenciation ça veut dire que vous
avez des qu'est-ce qu'on fait on on
jeallais dire on crée ce qu'on ce que
j'appelle du droit d'exception voyez
plutôt que se reposer des questions
aujourd'hui l'Alsace par exemple la
Bretagne aspire à nourrir des des
réflexions sur l'organisation des
collectivités faut se poser les les
bonnes questions faut dire c'est si on
ouvre la porte à la Corse d'autres
régions d'autres non il faut il faut
simplement se dire qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
différenciation est-ce que c'est faire
du droit d'exception c'est-à-dire avoir
un droit différent selon les territoires
ou est-ce que c'est dans un codre
constitutionnel permettre à certains
territoires d'avoir j'allais dire des
compétences qui soit différencié un
statut qui puisse être modifié différené
comme on l'a fait comme on l'a fait
pardon de dire sur la question
ultramarine on a des territoires qui ont
des statuts différents euh mais jusqu'où
vous êtes ré est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
accorder on imagine que sur la question
de la langue et de la question du peuple
corse qui sont des revendications le
Sénat s'y oppose mais est-ce que vous
êtes prêt à aller sur la question du
pouvoir législatif est-ce que là il faut
donner plus d'autonomie il faut il faut
peut-être assouplir plus d'autonomie
encore une fois j'attends j'attends de
voir les textes sincèrement je je serais
je serai mal honnête de de vous dire oui
ou non parce qu'on a été trop souvent
échaudé et et souvent je vais vous dire
ça débouche sur quoi ça débouche sur des
faux espoirs qui sont laissés à à ces
territoires et on crée de l'amertume on
crée de la frustration si on peut aller
si on peut avancer je pense que le Sénat
a toujours je le dis toujours et vous
pouvez regarder tous les travaux été au
rendez-vous de ces discussions et nous
sommes prêts à faire uvre utile mais
encore une fois il faut être très clair
les promesses à l'emporte-pèces
malheureusement ça ne débouche que
encore une fois sur sur de la
frustration et ça moi je m'y refuse le
message est passé merci on parlera des
passoirs thermiques tout à l'heure ce
sera évidemment le débat du club la
crise du logement on va continuer à
parler des élus on va aller chez vous
puisque c'est aussi l'actualité dans
votre département on va à priva
retrouver pierre Brunet bonjour Pierre
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste au Dauphiné Libéré et vous
allez revenir sur cette question de la
sécurité des élus avec un exemple
concret que vous relatez dans vos pages
oui tout à fait aujourd'hui dans nos
colonnes on parle du maire de berzem 180
habitants qui lundi dans lors du conseil
municipal et ben il a expliqué que il
subissait des menaces depuis euh
plusieurs années depuis 2020 et son
élection et donc euh qu'il souhaitait
euh en tout cas qu'il envisageait très
sérieusement de de quitter son poste euh
je voudrais savoir Monsieur le Sénateur
un maire qui dit euh je vais quitter mon
poste qu'est-ce qu'on peut lui dire là
maintenant pour qu'il réfléchisse et
qu'il qu'il revoit sa position très
concrètement alors c'est un sujet que je
connais par cœur parce que je connais
très bien bien ce ce maire on en a
discuté à plusieurs reprises euh j'ai eu
moi-même l'occasion d'interpeller euh à
la fois l'état sur ces sujets les forces
de de gendarmerie comme sur un un autre
cas avec la la mer de de Saint-Martial
qui a été confrontter euh jeis dire à à
des sujets similaires je crois qu'il
faut mettre encore une fois tous les
moyens sur la table que ce soit la
gendarmerie que ce soit l'état euh et
puis nous on a pris notre part en votant
ce ce ce texte en permettant justement
cette automatisation de de la protection
pour pour pour les élus et puis surtout
lui dire que nous sommes à à ses côtés
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
parce que il est impossible encore une
fois en 2023 dans notre pays d'un maire
qui uvre dans une commune de 180
habitants et croyez-moi c'est quelqu'un
qui avec le peu de moyens qu'il a avec
son équipe municipale a fait des choses
extraordinaires sur sa commune et voir
qu'il est parfois menacé
que sa famille fait l'objet d'attaque
pardon de le dire indigne ça n'est pas
possible donc je crois que ça doit être
là aussi une ardente priorité pour
l'ensemble je veux dire des autorités de
l'État des forces de sécurité dans notre
département que d'être au côté de ce
maire et de lui dire que ce qui est en
jeu encore une fois c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est l'avenir de
notre démocratie locale on ne peut pas
laisser un maire seul dans une commune
comme celle-là et je pense que c'est une
responsabilité des collectifs que nous
avons en tout cas moi je serai au côté
comme je l'ai toujours été de ce maire
et je ne manquerai pas de continuer à
intervenir avec l'ensemble des élus
parce qu'on est tous unis pour faire
front commun sur ce est-ce qu'il y a une
inquiétude particulière pour les maires
R qui se retrouve forcément plus àorter
d'engueelade voir plus malheureusement
bien sûr bien sûr et c'est pas
admissible c'est pas admissible qu'on en
soit à faire des menaces à avir parfois
des des lettres anonymes qu'on en arrive
à à des faits des délictueux sur je veux
dire les les biens de ces personnes là
mais mais mais où est-on pardon de de le
dire ça n'est pas possible donc je pense
que là aussi ça doit vraiment être une
priorité et c'est un crèf cœur que
d'imaginer qu'un maire est prêt à
démissionner alors qu'il s'investit pied
à pied pour sa commune pour des sujets
qui n'ont rien à faire dans le dans le
débat public ou dans la vie quotidienne
d'un élu pierre vous aviez une autre
question pour Mathie Darna
oui je par rapport à votre élection en
tant que premier président du Sénat qui
est donc toute récente euh savoir si
votre profil rural avait avait porté
votre votre
candidature je je je je je sais pas si
mon profil rural en tout cas je pense
que le Sénat c'est la chambre des
territoires euh je sais que le le le
président Larcher que mes collègues sont
très sensibles à cet équilibre entre
territoires urbains et territoires
ruraux si joséis je dirait que le le
Sénat c'est encore ce ce lieu cette
chambre on était très attentif ù nous
sommes très attentifs à ce qu'il se
passe dans les territoires ruraux avec
toutes les complexités les difficultés
que rencontrent notamment les élus mais
plus généralement les Françaises et les
Français qui vivent dans nos territoires
sur des questions très pratiques des
questions du quotidien comme les
mobilités l'accès à la santé on le voit
dans un département comme l'Ardèche la
téléphonie mobile des sujets très
concrets qui font le quotidien de nos
concitoyens et qui malheureusement sont
parfois un peu plus compliqués à traiter
quand on est en en Ardèche sur la
montagne ardéchoise dans des territoires
ruraux où on parfois de moyens et où là
encore je crois dans le rôle du Sénat
pour être une caisse de résonance à à
ces territoire et en tout cas en tant
que élu de ce département de l'Ardèche
et pour avoir parcouru dans le cadre du
rapport que j'ai rendu sur l'avenir de
la commune beaucoup de territoire je
pense que nous avons à faire à œuvrer
pour que encore une fois la ruralité
soit entendue et qu'elle bénéficie des
moyens nécessaires pour assurer son
développement merci merci Pierre Brunet
d'avoir été avec nous on regarde la une
du dauphinet dans son édition dromardesh
c'est le papilloma virirus la
vaccination a débuté c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci d'avoir été avec
nous merci Matthieu d'Arnaud d'avoir été
notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure à très bientôt évidemment
dans cette émission